großartige 47 Medaillen haben
heeressportlerinnen und heeressportler
in der abgelaufenen Saison bei Europa
und Weltmeisterschaften abgeräumt ich
einen
leistungssportleistungssportlerin vor
allem eines auszeichnet dass man einfach
nie aufgibt den Gesamtweltcup gewinnen
Eva pinkelnik im Skisprung
[Musik]
ganz klar zum Sportlerleben aber ich war
eigentlich immer mit einem Lächeln
[Musik]
rund 40 Athletinnen und Athleten Treffen
am Donnerstag im
Verteidigungsministerium zusammen um
etwas wohlverdientes überreich zu
bekommen dank und Anerkennung für
außergewöhnliche sportliche Leistungen
überreicht von Verteidigungsministerin
Claudia Tanner
des Bundesheer steht dahin und wir es
ist natürlich ein großer Unterstützung
dass mir die Biathlonsport ausüben
können und für die ist dann man sehr
dankbar ohne den hätte es nicht so weit
geschafft es ist tatsächlich so dass
ohne die Unterstützung von Bundeswehr
vor allem nach der Schule des einfach
nicht möglich wäre beim vorhin in
ransportarten so ist es noch ist also
wenn man damit der Schule fertig ist
dann war es mir wirklich immer zuerst
nicht wohin und da ist er für wichtig
dass man das Bundesheer hat ich habe
zuerst noch sogar noch den Umweg über
Studium genommen Anteil und dann bin ich
quasi zum Bundesheer gekommen und das
ist schon entscheidend was sonst sicher
nicht im Profisport gelandet
und das ist das worum es in Profisport
auch geht die frei werdenden Emotionen
wenn man den Erfolg realisiert die
Emotionen kamen immer noch hoch also
auch wenn die Rennen vor drei vier
Jahren mir nur anschauen
klingt das Gefühl wieder hoch und mal
erinnert sich sofort an jeden einzelnen
Moment sehr viele Erfolge schon feiern
dürfen AWM Medaillen Medaillen aber jede
einzelne Medaille hat ihre eigene
Emotion weil
immer überall andere Aufwand dahinter
steht und ähm die Situationen immer
unterschiedlich sein deswegen hat
wirklich jeder Erfolg sein eigenes seine
eigene Emotionen eigentlich emotionale
Momente gekommen um zu bleiben für das
ganze Leben
das ist ein wunderbarer Tag wo man danke
sagen kann wo man gratulieren kann so
ganz herausragenden Leistungen wirklich
einfach stolz und dankbar machen die
Sportlerinnen und Sportler haben
unglaubliches geleistet also alles Gute
toll toll für die nächste Saison sie
haben sie diesen Erfolg unglaublich
verdient